Guardian eyes up Verdean it worked  you're alive actually well you've been  dead a long time  eyes up Guardian your life know how long  I'm a ghost actually now I'm your ghost  and you well you've been dead a long  time  not even the light where is this ghost  not either the light where's his ghost  we may want to move back we've woken the  hive access key boss it's more  complicated  oh I think I initiated a fail-safe this  should lead us right to the grave the  world's grave not ours this should lead  us right to the grave the world's great  not ours can't we just stay here with  the murderous robots no little light  don't do that  can't we just stay here with the  murderous robots no little light don't  do that